[Music]
hey everybody this is gonna be my
Runaways finale video and Easter eggs
from the season I'll explain what's
going on with season two at the end of
the video because they were renewed for
second season I assume it will also be
ten episodes so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's a whole bunch of
Marvel stuff that's getting ready to
drop
but of course careful for spoilers from
the episode if you haven't seen it yet
so the biggest surprise that I saw in my
timeline is that episode 10 was the
actual finale because it ended on such a
non-explosive moment and you got that
flash-forward earlier in the season
where Chase was almost seeing a version
of the future where Los Angeles was
crumbling to the ground
[Music]
maybe they'll revisit that sometime
during season two like they actually
have a device they can see into the
future that seems like a pretty big deal
but the real action of the finale was
revealing what was at the bottom of that
hole that Jonah wanted to get to like
what is that living rock that's giving
off the energy that powers his body like
he gives off this white light the same
energy that gave Molly her powers as a
child and as you probably detective
they've combined Jonah's character with
the Gabor 'im from the comics so a lot
of people are wondering if there's
something that's alive at the bottom of
that hole is that the actual Gabor 'im
and what it seems like is going on is
they're using the church of Gabor 'm to
sort of wink at the actual real-life
gods the Gabor I'm from the comics and
instead they're turning Jonah into the
big bat of the series he's one of the
Majesty nians and instead of getting
their power from just general solar
radiation like they absorb the light of
the Sun and then they could turn that
into energy blast they use it to fly
they actually get their energy from the
life force that is trapped in those
rocks but as we've seen through the
sacrifices they can also convert normal
human beings into that same type of
energy so there's some sort of life
force that they absorb and turn into
energy the Jonah needs in order to
prolong his life we don't know how old
he is he seems like he's at least
hundreds of years old if not thousands
and that's why he needs to recharge so
much because the majesty nians like
their powers work like a battery so
Karolina can give off those energy
blasts but eventually she'll need to
recharge or she'll lose her abilities
which is why Jonah's freaking out at the
end of the finale because he exhausted
most of his energy in that fight with
Karolina so he's to recharge before he
turns back into the flakey white person
on the alien respirator for the most
part it seems like we're not gonna meet
the actual Gabor room from the comics
and they're using the Church of Gabor
more as a parody of like the crazy cult
organizations that you find around Los
Angeles take your pick there are many so
it seems mostly like they're winking at
that with the church and it's mostly
just a front for Jonah to get the source
of his power without access to the
actual source which is buried beneath
Los Angeles maybe that happened eons ago
like maybe he got trapped on the earth
and he's from another planet
can't get to it till someone smart
enough in the technologies good enough
to give him a device that can get him to
it most of you probably guessed that the
pot at the end of the finale has chases
father and it he's finally come back to
life so Joan is excited because it just
means that they'll be able to fix the
drill and get to his power the minor
change that they made is because they've
turned Jonah into more of the big bat of
the series the parents had become more
sympathetic and if you're confused about
who ratted them out to the police like
they're in that lineup if you know these
people they're connected to this murder
that was Alex's father where he says
don't worry I'm gonna take care of it he
was trying to do a good thing but the
kids only see that as a threat so it
still seems like they're building
towards a fight between the kids and
their parents where they genuinely run
away from home and become more of an
organized team like they tried to run
away at the end of the finale the series
is called runaways at some point they
had to run away from home if you want to
follow along in the comic obviously
they're starting with Brian Kay Vaughn's
run if they go enough seasons they might
push into Joss Whedon territory but most
people don't like that run as much as
they'd like Brian capons
they're not burning through the comic
book that quickly and they did kill off
a couple of the parents that are still
alive in the comic but that was mostly
for production issues this is there were
too many characters for them to handle
so that's why they killed them off and
Molly in the comics is a mutant but
because this whole Fox's Disney deal
hasn't been worked out yet they don't
have the right to use the word mutant so
that's why her power derives from the
source of Jonah's power but if there was
any confusion Jonah is just a
combination of the majesty nians in the
myth of the Gabor 'im in the comics so I
don't think we're actually gonna meet
the Gabor 'im but those of you asking
how this is connected to the Avengers
like why haven't they talked about the
incident the Chitauri invasion the
Battle of New York any of the big things
that are going on in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right now like
infinity war that's going to be
happening in a couple months in the
comics the majesty nians aren't that big
of a deal they're an alien race that are
at war with the scrolls which is more
Captain Marvel territory Avengers for
stuff if you're wondering how powerful
Jonah is compared to some of the other
Avengers I would think that Captain
America could probably eat one of their
blasts and if you remember Iron Man in
that first Avengers film how Thor
tried to shoot him with a light
in bold but instead of harming him it
supercharged his armor I think the same
thing would happen if Jonah tried to
soak Iron Man with a blast
[Music]
how about that but we'll see if they try
to tie their race to stuff that's going
on in the Marvel cosmic universe because
they do try to connect things when
possible so it makes sense that he came
to earth looking for special power or he
was stranded on earth because he was
trying to escape some sort of war but as
of the end of the finale they haven't
completely revealed Jonah's backstory so
there might be other minor changes that
they've made and aside from them teasing
some of the character dynamics like
characters hooking up within the team
and some of them maybe betraying each
other down the road the only other real
big easter egg from that last episode
was when they gave Old Lace her name
from the comics so that's what she calls
her the way they did it was a little
clumsy on the TV show but they had to
get there somehow like Arsenic and Old
Lace isn't something that a typical
teenager would be talking about either
way it was fine but just let me know in
the comments what do you think of the
serious soap bar and obviously season
two will probably drop either in
November or October I think they'll get
it out before the end of the year but I
think it'll also be ten episodes and I
know there's a whole bunch of other
Marvel TV that's getting ready to start
this year plus DC stuff too like we have
Titans I have new videos for some of
that stuff that I'll try to get out by
the end of the week but while you wait
for everything click here for the new
trailer for the Superman prequel TV
series learn all about Green Lantern
coming on the show eventually and click
here for brand new Deadpool thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]